الاستعجال انتقال اليها لان الظروف غير
غير مواتيه للنقل لظروف امنيه
المشهد مدى يجري هناك مشاهداتي
[موسيقى]
الان انسحبت قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي من
داخل البلده القديمه في المدينه بعد يعني
على الاقل ثلاث الى اربع ساعات من هذه
العمليه ولكنها تحاصر عدد من المداخل ولكن
سنبدا الان بالحصيله النهائيه التي وصلت
قبل حوالي سبع دقائق من وزاره الصحه
الفلسطينيه الحصيله حتى الان سته شهداء
فلسطينيين سقطوا برصاص الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي واكثر من 70 فلسطينيا اصيبوا
بجراح هناك بعض الاصابات الخاطره الموجوده
في غرف العمليات في عدد من مستشفيات
المدينه بالطبع الطواقم الطبيه واجهت
صعوبه كبيره في الوصول الى المصابين وذلك
قد يكون احد الاسباب الذي رفع عدد الشهداء
من بين الشهداء الذين سقطوا على الاقل
نتحدث عن شهيدين هما من
الفلسطينيين تم محاصرتهما داخل منزل لم
تتضح بعد المعلومات ان كان هناك عدد اخر
من المقاومين ان كانوا داخل المنزل ولكن
وفق طاقمنا الذي يتواجد هناك وايضا الصور
الاوليه التي وصلتنا واضح وما نؤكده ان
بالفعل قوات الاحتلال استخدمت صواريخ
اميرجا
وقصفت المنزل وقبل ذلك كنا قد استمعنا
لوصيه نشرها احد الشهداء وهو حسام سليم
وتحدث باسمه وقال انا لن استسلم انا
ورفيقي
ودعى المقاومين الفلسطينيين والشعب
الفلسطيني الى عدم الاستسلام ومواصله
مقاومه الاحتلال الاسرائيلي وعدم انزال
السلاح هذا معناه انه حتى وان كانت قد
نفذت ذخيره المقاومين في داخل هذا المنزل
الذي حصل على الاقل لثلاث ساعات معناه ان
هناك
عمليه عسكريه نوعيه قام بها الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي بالطبع بمساعده الشباك وحرس
الحدود واعدت الويه من الجيش الاسرائيلي
لانه منذ لحظه دخول قواتها الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي نشر الناطق العسكري باسمي
الجيش الاسرائيلي بيان قال فيه الجيش الان
يقوم بعمليه امنيه في داخل البلده القديمه
في نابلس عاده عندما يتم نشر هكذا بيان
معناه انه هناك عمليه كبيره وموسعه نتيجه
معلومات استخباريه وصلت لقوات الاحتلال
باختلاف اذرعها نحن الان كما ترى وسط
مدينه نابلس عبد الصمد هناك الان بدات
الحركه تعود شيئا فشيئا ولكن كما اكدت لك
قوات الاحتلال لم تنسحب بالكامل من داخل
المحافظه هي انسحبت فقط من داخل البلده
القديمه بالطبع هناك حاله
عارمه من الغضب الان بدانا نستمع لرصاص في
الهواء يبدو ان عدد من المقاومين
الفلسطينيين نعم هذا ليس من قوات الاحتلال
هذا يبدو مقاومين فلسطينيين يقومون باطلاق
النار في الهواء نتحدث عن سته شهداء منذ
في هذه العمليه الشهداء هناك انباء عن
سقوط طفل المستشفيات الطفل
يدعى النمر الميناوي ويبلغ من العمر 14
عاما ما دقه هذه المعلومات
بالفعل نعم بالفعل حسب وزاره الصحه
الفلسطينيه هناك فتى فلسطيني استشهد يبلغ
من العمر 14 عاما ولكن الاسوا ايضا ان
هناك مسن يبلغ من العمر 72 عاما وراينا
حتى شريط فيديو كيف ان هذا المسن وامام
اعين قوات الاحتلال كان ملقى مدرجا
بالدماء على الارض منع الطواقم الاسعاف من
الوصول اليه ماذا يمكن حسب الاهالي هنا ان
يضر او يشكل اي خطر هذا المسن الذي يبلغ
من العمر 72 عاما على قوات الاحتلال ايضا
هذا الفتى الذي يبلغ من العمر 14 عاما
بالطبع يعني يعني عبد الصمد نحن لدينا
الاسماء الموثقه من قبل وزاره الصحه
الفلسطينيه ولكن لا داعي لذكرها حتى يتم
ابلاغ كامل كل العائلات باستشهاد ابنائها
بالطبع الان على ما يبدو هناك تحضيرات لا
لا نعرف ان كان سيتم تشييع هذه الكوكب
الجديد من الشهداء عصر هذا اليوم ام سيتم
التاجيل حتى يا يوم الغد لان كل الامور
متوتره جدا لان الجميع كان يعتقد وفق
التصريحات السياسيه من الجانب الامريكي او
من قبل حتى عدد من المسؤولين الاسرائيليين
وايضا عدد من المسؤولين الفلسطينيين وبعد
جلسه مجلس الامن الدولي انه لن يكون هكذا
شكل من اشكال الاقتحامات ولكن راينا اليوم
هذه العمليه العسكريه وسقوط هذا العدد من
الشهداء حتى صباح اليوم كنا نتحدث عن 53
شهيدا الان اضيف اليهم سته اذا نتحدث عن
59 شهيدا في اقل من شهر ويعني اقل من
شهرين هذا العدد من بينهم بالطبع 12 طفل
وامراه اذا العدد كبير نوعا ما نرى يعني
البلده القديمه والاسواق الخارجيه كلها
مغل هناك الان حداد عام وشامل وكامل هناك
تجمع كبير للاهالي لان ايضا كان هناك عبر
مكبرات الصوت مطالبه من قبل المقاومين
الفلسطينيين وتحديدا من عرين الاسود وايضا
كتيبه بلاطه بتوجه المواطنين الى داخل
البلده القديمه لفك الحصار عن المنزل الذي
كان محاصر ومسانده الشبان في داخله ولكن
قوات الاحتلال منعت احد من الوصول هناك
كانت تطلق الرصاص الحي في كل الاتجاهات
حتى ان من بين المصابين ثلاثه صحفيين
فلسطينيين احدهم قال لنا ان الشظيه كانت
قريبه من اذنه وكانت يمكن ان تدخل الى
الوجه اذا اليوم كان هناك حمله شرسه اتجاه
الكل سواء المقاومين الاهالي كبار السن
الاطفال الصحفيين الطواقم الطبيه اذا
عمليه عسكريه شامله بالطبع رئيس الوزراء
الفلسطيني اعتبر عمليه بانها ارهاب منظم
قال هذا ما قاله بالطبع الرئاسه
الفلسطينيه دانت وطالبه الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه بالتدخل